it's the whole risk thing that you
mentioned is nice
is to be able to estimate like how risky
is this situation
that's really important to understand
one other thing you mentioned comparing
comma and autopilot is that um
something about the haptic feel of the
way combo controls the car
when things are uncertain like it
behaves a little bit more uncertain when
things are uncertain
that's kind of an interesting point and
then autopilot is much more confident
always even when it's uncertain until it
runs into trouble
yeah that's that's a funny thing i
actually mentioned that to elon i think
and then the first time
we talked he wasn't biting is like
communicating uncertainty
i guess comet doesn't really communicate
uncertainty explicitly it communicates
it through haptic
feel like what's the role of
communicating uncertainty do you think
oh we do some stuff explicitly like we
do detect the lanes when you're on the
highway and we'll show you how many
lanes we're using to drive with
you can look at where it thinks the
lanes are you can look at um
the path and yeah we want to be better
about this we're actually hiring
i want to hire some new ui people ui
people you mentioned this because it's
such an
it's a ui problem too right it's we have
we have a great designer now
but you know we need people are just
going to like build this and debug these
uis
qt people and gt is that what the ui has
done with
skt we're moving the new ui is in qt
c plus plus qt tesla is it
yeah we had some react stuff in there
the react js would just react react is
his own language right
react native reaction native reaction is
a javascript framework
yeah it's all it's all based on
javascript but it's
you know i like c plus
you